on various hey what's going on everybody
for first we feast I'm Sean Evans and
you're watching hot ones it's the show
with hot questions and even hotter wings
and today I'm joined by t-pain he's been
a billboard mainstay for damn near ten
years he has a lot of crazy food
theories that I can't wait to ask about
great and he's got a new single with lil
yachty dan Bilzerian yes man oh right in
the tee shirt to match tee shirt to
match and the shades I'll just to hide
my pain and anguish how are you with hot
food I'm afraid you're afraid let me
reveal oh you're both somebodies okay
I'm just not ready at all you're not
mother the fumes are making my eyes
bleed already well that's an interesting
start it is
I wasn't so a lot no is wonder are these
hot on it go cameras in here for a
minute they call the [ __ ] now who's
nothing Bri Nana watch the show so much
mm-hmm I got a technique okay okay this
is interesting how technique I like to
see people drinking milk because it
helps but they drink milk right in the
middle
mm-hmm they stop drinking milk when they
start getting around you know then when
they need it you gotta start with a milk
because it's girlcode' your stomach and
it's not going to put Wow
t-pain spent some time on ghouls mm-hmm
I want to start with Dan Bilzerian
because he seems like an interesting
muse for a t-pain song you ever met him
have you ever counseled him Adam last
night last night last night so that's
why we needed the shade right right it
was it was a is it really bikinis and
assault rifles floor-to-ceiling or is he
overcompensating Instagram it's for real
I got to his penthouse it's a whole
floor of a giant building everything's
white don't know how they keep the place
clean it's a mate meet you at the door
and which is cool and I hear from
upstairs did they make it up there and
we're like yeah we're down here
immediately just [ __ ] pouring out the
goddamn window
I mean it's like a goddamned like a
clown car goddamn Stampede like a that's
just one by one just coming out the room
just getting ready everybody get ready
for the club he comes out there's normal
guy
just kickin it like nothing's going on
in here like hey how's it going
he's eating grapes and [ __ ] and yeah we
talked for a minute and then we have it
is a million dollar truck and go through
the club that's how you do it with all
the chicks I don't know how that works
can I ask you about the song because
there's an interesting lyric you go with
sick a dock [ __ ] I'm rich is thug [ __ ]
I'm rich is for your loves get sick a
dog you can stick a dog which is
interesting cuz the song is already it
already goes there but it goes they're
sick of duck um there's not many more
things you can say that will be as
offensive and that would also rhyme with
riches [ __ ] oh
yeah the world of teeth they absolutely
yep watch this no oh the milk first then
the wing okay I need to ask you about
the Waze app because you being a future
voice on that is amazing they let me
have it
Billy guys we better go yeah they let me
do what I want to do man you know they
obviously say don't don't say you know
can encourage speeding and drunk driving
is it but no good mani let me they let
me go all the way I always think people
try to pronounce that and I don't thank
you for now isn't right either but why
would you go and it's a yuca Tucker now
you could check up here you could tech
oh one of those want to know what I
write uh-huh at first we feast we've
covered your food theories extensively a
good reason because they're amazing
so I've pulled great food tweets from
the last year I want you to read it and
then expand on it okay because these
require more than 140 K that's okay I
get that
here's the page a night of heavy
drinking eat a slice of cheese after
every drink the cup the constipation
will prevent the beer shits in the
morning you're welcome
it's worked for me it's very hard to sit
out there an item cheese and beer I'll
you know that's up I can only eat one
thing at a time like if I get a burger
and fries I have to finish the fries
before I take one bite of the burger I'm
the same way I'm exactly the same way
you don't want to mix that that those
taste like I said I don't like it when
shake getting mixed I don't like the
juice from my corn to touch my corn
breathe I've seen people eat chicken and
I drink beer and that is just not like
whip the chicken they still chewing the
chicken and drinking beer
sorry frat boys disgusting [ __ ]
yeah hey this barbecuey pretty good
right wait
damn [ __ ] hot wait a minute t-pain
the middle finger isn't working
can I get an update on the ghost because
you once you were living in a haunted
your house is haunted right you have two
ghosts and they're fighting each other
yeah the bad one went away actually
there was a bad ghost there was a bad
goes and a good ghost and the good ghost
was keeping the bad girls at bay so you
know any any kind of would be attacks
would be you know interrupted by the
good go you had a psychic come to the
house Oh a so many people come to us
there's weird [ __ ] happening in there
man tell me weird [ __ ] and then told me
about the psychic coming over so the
weird [ __ ] there's door slamming there's
pennies being lined up in my hallway and
weird times with nights wow there's a
sounds of people walking up and down my
stairs and we go there you know we got
cameras everywhere so we you know we
check all the cameras nobody everybody
is asleep now you know it's it's it's a
lot of weird [ __ ] some scary [ __ ]
but a psychic over and she said that
this guy his name is William and his
kids got killed on that property right
in front of them - Wow by the people
that took the land from his it's a lot
but apparently his kids got killed in
front of him he's very angry and he was
also rich as hell but he was very
miserable so that's why he walked around
the house a lot we see him on the yard a
lot of times and he's a miserable
disease just walking around
he doesn't dresser though this one is
the hot one sauce you know about this
I've heard it's really really good but
you've heard people talk I got it for
you so they're good do you go to the
strip club with the same intensity that
you used to because I remember during
your Howard Stern you you said 15 times
a month uh
however today they're like 30 31 days
you're going every other day yeah still
no no not still but back then
it was yeah it was very it was it was it
was intense Jesse McCartney was doing a
radio interview did this ever get back
to you because he told a story about
going to the strip club with you hmm
about how you picked him up in an orange
lambo when you got to the strip club you
handed him a paper bag with 15 to 20
grand in it yeah it was a that was dumb
tell me about that because they didn't
spin at all and he kept it I mean I just
put a bunch of big black ants in them
and gave us much money taking fare and
it shocked the hell out
it definitely was uh he was not
expecting that at all my mouth is on
fire
this next part is called explain next
row and you are a fan of the show so you
know it's playing that gram we've done a
deep dive on your Instagram we pulled
some interesting pictures that just need
more context here's my theory yeah
another way I didn't eat before this so
you know I was juicing and you know
getting getting the fluids going mm-hmm
so right after this I can just [ __ ]
immediately because I wouldn't have none
in my stomach but this it's gonna be a
Coolio situation I feel like the office
absolutely obviously Friday which okay
I'm just gonna oh oh
thinking the national anthem at the
Dodgers game Oh God I was nervous more
nervous than taking the stage absolutely
the DEF CON sir cuz I knew I'll do this
was gonna be more judge than anything
and people have gone after you harder
than they would anybody else say
anything anything because they figure I
can't I already can't say it's already
got it
preconceived noses I houseboat to do to
[ __ ] but the crazy thing was I was
closing my eyes the whole time to try to
remember the words and then I open my
eyes and they had all the words on the
job oh this is interesting
yeah man that's it going how's it going
she painted Michael Jackson II painted
Michael Jackson they a lot of people
think that's fake this is this is right
after I drop bartender and didn't she
tell you that it was the first hard copy
asougi that he bought here so it was the
first physical sitting here bonding for
years
do you remember the face to face do you
remember the room that you remember how
it went down
yes we went in a in a guesthouse at the
ranch that is bigger than my regular
house he had on the booth he had on the
the famous booths the 30 Diana's like
yeah to lose man like pajamas Nick
Michael Jackson has a really neat voice
it's nice to say that but that's what
surprised me them really it's not like
the interview public persona situation
it's totally different like Prince
really it's amazing yeah it's like way
down there I didn't I didn't I didn't
expect that but alright so this one is
pain 100%
I like the name pain 100% so that's good
t-pain 100% there it is
oh whoa well not only is it a shit-hot
dog mm-hmm what is mega hot mm-hmm
so I know you're a huge Game of Thrones
fan yes yes yes who do you thinks gonna
end up on the Iron Throne
I'll definitely Jon Snow you think Jon
Snow Jon Snow is gonna end up bringing
the [ __ ] out of Khaleesi ah yeah the
geekiness doesn't stop with Game of
Thrones oh no no no do you play video
games yeah stream um absolutely get all
into it with my headset a little bit
wait no let me what come on Hotel Wi-Fi
you're never really calm about it
do you trash talk do you get all into
that I'll try not to try to talk as much
because I'm trash you get it cuz that's
the whole thing cuz those kids are out
of control I don't get it as much
because they want to be friends so they
know you're yeah I was playing Division
I was I'm on ps4 and this kid so my my
name's I guess on my tag and of course
it's like Teddy phantasms yeah yeah it
was just a real team pain and I wouldn't
say anything because I don't want to get
into a conversation right right but I
was level 5 this [ __ ] was level
30 and I'm like yo what's up man it was
like I said then you start bringing his
friends on and they're all level 30
so just so yeah I know if somebody else
is a higher level than you they can make
you level up faster that's why I'm BAM
so I talked to this guy one time at 9
p.m. 4 p.m. comes we still playing like
I'm I'm in it I can you're just leveling
up I'm leveling up I'm just I'm making
I'm making the dudes dreams come true he
asked me questions about having like yep
keep bad what's on the left yeah keep
going just keep running these things
like you know these dudes are powerful
so you need to wait back here you need
to hop behind this I'm like cool I'm not
coming out at all y'all [ __ ] autumn over
because I want to just let me level up
at hand I'm good that's using your
celebrity for good right absolutely
I'm starting to save the wings now
because I think I'm gonna eat them later
Oh mmm Oh for this next part you're the
king of haberdashery got the greatest
hats in the game how would ever oh but I
want to show you some classic iconic hat
legends I just want you to react to them
the things you like the things that
don't like is their actual neighborhood
how about I hope Benedict the sixteenth
with the sombrero on oh man I got thing
you like the look it matches my matches
they got the white and gold going
it's a royalty thing yeah ha ha ha LL
Cool J ATS Eric Engel funk with it you
gave everything at all you can [ __ ] that
I know that's that's still going people
still wearing those so he's me I don't
know if he has stocking gang over that
brother get a smart move back Queen
Elizabeth on a global scale one of the
best always always I don't know I think
they they take pieces of her dress and
make the hat out of that I think they're
all her dresses are supposed to be
longer than they are I think this the
rest of the material is on top of a
[ __ ] head it's so hard to measure at
to the club through their clothes I
guess it's always the exact same color
about actor Bill Murray he's great with
the golf house and he's so great
any de Ville Marie does to just iconic
hey this red fatigue I'm gonna guess
fatigue bucket hat on and he has a pink
polo under it with the goddamn collar
flipped up I don't I don't know a more
physical representation of I don't give
a [ __ ]
you know immediately small feasible we
just follow behind
Oh
Cassie the back your hands real quick
yeah up there it is yeah oh the guy
Jackie Jackie
oh yeah um tattoo oh he's talked to me
about this I needed a meme catcher and
it wasn't too many greats out there and
you know that I respect you a lot so why
not go with the confuse Jackie I put on
my hand so every time somebody say
something stupid I never do this
ah and then kind of works yourself out
this is [ __ ] up
mm-hmm this is bad you have tattoo
tattooed on your neck too right tattoo
tattoo and I had a horrible one done
over here that says another tattoo wait
hold on let me see yeah
oh wow one of these is I I can't thank
man besides those three is there another
tattoo T's that you think I would be
fascinated by Tom I have a facebook like
over here but around anything you don't
have to like me big internet sort of
influence on the ink I'm gonna internet
a lot oh man tattoo Oh God
oh [ __ ] alright so my mouth is like
season up yeah having a tongue here
thankfully though we are approaching the
finish line make it this is Blair's
Megadeth sauce with liquid rage liquid
raised that's always the the seventh
point I hear people read about dab in
the last wing in what um what's up
t-pain I don't know that know if I can
do any more I don't know how life works
do you want a DAB you don't have to dad
t-pain you don't have to dab you don't
have to dad I'm gonna do what you get
like on the intro of the show when I win
comes across the thing mm-hmm
okay thank you that that's a little it's
a little schmear seems more safe in
event of death what like what happens I
what does my wife get whatever you left
her damn so be careful cuz that is a
glob I don't want ya I don't want you
scooping that be careful we don't lose
to you
how does no ingredients on the planet
Earth multiple hot ingredients not just
one pepper and I'm good let me ask you
this is this easier than you thought it
would be is that what you thought it
would be is it harder than you thought
up until up until Rogue rogue as I was
like I'll do this no no no I look like I
got my girl lost in Walmart I've already
told everybody that's like I don't like
you know I'm gonna do hot ones I'm not
gonna be available for today that's good
that's someone who knows what they're
doing have like two more hours of a
movie joke no okay I am
so I can probably just boop-boop just
boot damn and let's eat and then we are
gonna have some fun horny goodness me
you think you think this is like a some
sick game yeah absolutely I agree with
uh who's saying it I'm say the best
[ __ ] Jordan Jordan Peele he
said you found something you can do you
made us all around it oh oh god I think
I'm gonna kiss my wife for three weeks
okay oh okay
so that is not talking right now I can't
imagine I'm the first one to pull this
stunt god damn it
you know what this is this is the t-pain
mic mmm the I am t-pain Mike with the
t-pain effect I'm hoping we can do is
while we're dying on this blares
Megadeth sauce huh as I would like to
sing my favorite t-pain hook maybe you
could sing what are your favorite
classic t-pain hooks sisters we call
Blair whist and then we could save one
and then we'll get to your plug you
ready to get me belt it out you get you
got
to go way to live you got to know
your turn yeah boy who I thought I kind
of nailed that it was on point ten out
of ten we got it mister its rid of dirt
and grime and just made mr. what if
there is a license it was beautiful and
it was amazing and t-pain you cleared
the board
yeah we'll give you it to go and it's
all good man I keep looking
the floor is yours this camera that
camera that camera with the people know
what you have going on in your life so
you gonna do a new single dan Bilzerian
featuring lil yachty it's a dope song if
you want to have fun [ __ ] strangers take
up a new show Joyride on Esquire network
oh my god Tuesday's it's here huh
I didn't figure it out none of my
theories work if you got any questions
before coming on the show don't text you
know ask me [ __ ]
hey that's all Eric don't get don't get
cocky
just take your time and drink up to not
say where you were